The galaxy far far away has enjoyed one of
the biggest and most complicated world of
extended universe stories in history, even
if the movies themselves are the only canon
future films will follow.
You might think that just seven movies would
put a limit on the wild theories fans could
create to show the Star Wars saga in a whole
new light – but you would be wrong.
Here are 10 Star Wars Theories That Change
Everything.
Chewbacca: The Rebel Spy
Think about it: if Obi-Wan Kenobi and Luke
Skywalker hadn’t stumbled onto Han Solo
in the first movie, the pilot never would
have joined the rebellion, or become one of
its top generals.
What if it wasn’t a coincidence?
Chewbacca is actually the first person Obi-Wan
talks to in the Tatooine cantina, and winds
up joining the rebellion along with his pilot
– the same rebellion born out of the slaughter
of the Jedi that Chewbacca witnessed firsthand
in Revenge of the Sith.
If he knew Yoda, he could have known any number
of Jedi, including Anakin Skywalker.
Did Obi-Wan tell him Luke’s true power and
importance, and Chewie made sure Han joined
the fight?
We’ll never know, but it’s too good to
a theory to ignore.
Luke Was The Emperor’s True Apprentice
It seems pretty stupid in hindsight that Obi-Wan
hid Luke from his father by leaving him with
Anakin’s family on his home planet.
Even if Anakin couldn’t bring himself to
track his children down, the Emperor definitely
would have – but what if the Emperor didn’t
want Luke killed?
He was in no hurry to die at his apprentice’s
hands, and even tried to recruit Luke as his
new student before he died at Vader’s hands.
Vader wound up scarred, missing limbs and
close to death, so the Emperor keeping him
close to eventually lure his more powerful
son into the open makes a lot of sense.
The Ewoks Ate The Stormtroopers
When the Rebels first meet the Ewoks, it’s
only C-3PO who keeps the adorable creatures
from cooking and eating them.
Keep that in mind when you get to the original
saga’s finale, and the Ewoks are celebrating
their victory, dancing, drinking, and playing
Stormtrooper helmets li9ke drums.
But… they totally just took those helmets
and left the bodies in the forest… right?
We’re half convinced you can spot piles
of chewed-clean bones somewhere in the scene,
but realize that plenty of the Stormtroopers
were injured, not killed in the battle, and
those Ewoks become a lot less cute.
Darth Jar Jar
Sure, it’s a silly theory, but trying to
make sense out of the most hated Star Wars
character is understandable.
How can Jar Jar Binks be so stupid, yet so
lucky and important all at the same time?
Easy: he was working with the Sith the whole
time.
How else do you explain his decision to hand
power of the Senate over to the future Emperor?
Pure cluelessness?
Nope, we see a secret alliance between two
cold hearted political operatives.
And his friends never saw it coming.
Boba Fett Killed Luke’s Family
Every fan remembers the moment Luke returns
home to find his aunt and uncle burned down
to skeletons, their bodies literally disintegrated
off of the bones while their home sits in
flames.
But it doesn’t look like anything the Stormtroopers
did before or since, leading some to think
that killing the family was hired out to a
bounty hunter who happened to be in the area
– the legendary Boba Fett.
Besides making the bounty hunter’s role
in the saga a bit more meaningful, it also
turns his exchange with Vader in Empire Strikes
Back an inside joke (insert clip of Vader
with the bounty hunters, turning to Boba when
he says “NO distintegrations”).
They learned the hard way: burning Skywalkers
down to their skeletons is a great motivation
for a nearby hero.
Padme Never Loved Anakin
Sure, this one might be a bit of a reach,
but you can’t blame fans for trying to explain
why Padme Amidala would ever fall in love
with the awkward, stalker-ish Anakin Skywalker.
The theory basically says that Anakin slowly
used the Force to manipulate Padme into caring
for him, whether on purpose or by accident.
Or, you could look at it another way: if Anakin
was created out of the Force to bring balance,
the Force may have sensed his turn to the
Dark Side
ahead of time – and got to work on making
some children to fix their father’s mistakes.
Han Solo is a Force User
He may not believe in The Force when he first
meets the movie’s star Jedi, but Han Solo
sure fights like someone sensitive to it.
Think about it: how many times did Han seem
to escape inescapable situations, avoid death
by inches, or dodge blaster fire with style?
The Force Awakens showed Rey was just as good
a pilot as Han before she even KNEW she was
channeling the Force, so the same could be
true for Han.
And considering how important he is to the
Rebel victory, The Force making sure he lived
to achieve it makes sense.
Rey’s a Kenobi, Not a Skywalker
From the first looks at Rey in The Force Awakens,
fans speculated that she was truly the daughter
of Luke Skywalker, and there were plenty of
hints to fuel the rumors.
But one theory suggests Rey wasn’t left
on a backwater planet by a Skywalker, but
a Kenobi – specifically, Obi-Wan’s child.
After all, it’s Obi-Wan’s voice that Rey
hears when she touches Luke’s lightsaber,
and the former Jedi Master has had romances
in the Clone Wars TV series.
If the theory was true, it would make the
Star Wars sage not just about the Skywalkers,
but Anakin and Obi-Wan – two friends who
became like brothers, betrayed eachother,
only for their grandchildren (Kylo and Rey)
to finally restore a balance.
Not to mention giving Luke Skywalker a version
of ‘the student becoming the master’ that
no fan would ever forget.
The Jedi Weren’t The Heroes
We all know the story: the Jedi are betrayed
from within by the evil Sith, and the people
of the galaxy suffer as a result.
But that story has some problems.
For starters, the Jedi Code said they weren’t
supposed to attack or rule over anyone, and
must respect all life, even that of their
enemies.
Now look at the galaxy they lived in: attacking
everywhere they felt it right, leading an
army on distant battlefields, and even deciding
to attack and kill a democratically appointed
leader because he was the sole survivor of
their ancient enemies.
They may not be the villains of the Star Wars
universe, but they’re not the heroes, either.
If The Force wasn’t there to help them prevent
their end – maybe it was for a reason.
The Rebels Killed Trillions
There’s one major problem in depicting the
Empire and Emperor as purely evil: mainly,
that the galactic senate was an absolute mess,
with the so-called peaceful Jedi looking to
stop a coalition of planets from actually
separating legally.
The theory that the Emperor was actually on
the right track gets even bigger, too, since
his use of The Force allowed him to see things
the Jedi missed – which may have included
the invasion of the Yuuzhan Vong, an alien
civilization that spent thousands of years
reaching the Star Wars galaxy, and emerging
just 25 years after the Rebels won… by blowing
up not one, but two moon-sized superweapons.
That left the galaxy undefended, and while
they won the war in the end, it cost the lives
of over 600 TRILLION sentient beings.
Was the Emperor trying to fortify the galaxy
to prevent such a slaughter?
We’ll never know, since Disney erased that
bit of the story for The Force Awakens…
for obvious reasons.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite Star Wars
theories?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.